demain le juge courrois entendra
Philippe de Villier l'excofondateur du
RPF apparaît-il des choses à révéler sur
le financement de ce parti des choses
qui pourraient être proches du dossier
actuellement instruit par le juge tout
cela reste encore assez vague mais le
divorce pascois de Villier lui devient
un véritable affrontement reportage
Arnaud Boutet hier soir lors des vœux du
conseil général des hautes scènes
Charles pascoy a serré de nombreuses
mains mais celui qui est aussi le
président du RPF ne voulait surtout pas
aborder le sujet qui fâche monsieur
mercred non écoutez
éeou plus
parler Philippe deviler quant à lui a
décidé de parler à la veille de son
entretien avec le juge courroi il veut
justifier sa démarche me frappe beaucoup
sur
l'affairean l'affaire
pasqu c'est quand même la loi du silence
ça veut dire qu'il a loi de la
solidarité mafieuse qui serait
supérieure à la loi de la vérité de la
justice ben moi je brise cette loi du
silence l'ancien vice-président du RPF
veut exposer au juges ses doutes sur le
financement de son ancien parti
plusieurs lettres en témoignent le 11
juillet dernier Philippe debillier écrit
cher Charles le désordre de ce mouvement
sa gestion fantaisiste son endettement
anormal sont à mon sens incompatible
avec les obligations morales et légales
qui sont les nôtres 7 jours plus tard le
style et le ton ont changé monsieur le
Président je n'ai pas confiance dans la
manière dont le secrétaire général gère
les fonds du mouvement cette lettre sera
celle de sa démission les juges dont
Philippe courois s'intéresse à des gros
donateurs du RPF et notamment Marth
Mondoloni domicilié au Gabon elle
figurait sur la liste RPF aux
européennes les juges tenteront de
savoir s'il existe un lien entre le
financement du RPF et l'enquête sur le
trafic d'armes vers
l'Afrique